das alleine war schon eine sensation vor
einigen wochen wurde im sibirischen
kammer frost ein 40.000 jahre altes
fohlen gefunden und es ist auch ziemlich
gut erhalten und jetzt das ein
forschungsteam will das pferd klonen
wie das genau funktionieren soll und wie
realistisch es ist dass wir so
ausgestorbene arten wieder aufleben
lassen können erfahrt ihr jetzt bei
klicks und science fiction
hier gibt es täglich neue science videos
abonniert den kanal gerne herzlich
willkommen das ist wirklich ein
sensationsfund ende august hatte das
russische forschungsteam das fohlen der
ausgestorbenen art aequo ihn nennen sie
es aufgespürt und zwar in einem 100
meter tiefen krater der auch als maul
der hölle bekannt ist im nordosten
zwischen darabos der tiger ja und dieser
per mappus hatte dafür gesorgt dass das
fossil super konserviert wurde dazu
einer der beteiligten forscher simon
gregory der körper des tieres greene
ohne schäden erhalten sogar das fell ist
noch vorhanden aber nicht nur das auch
der schwanz die haut des tieres und die
ufer sind noch gut erhalten äußerst
selten bei solch alten kunden denn das
forschungsteam ist sich sicher der bund
ist zwischen 30 und 40 tausend jahre alt
das forschungsteam vermutet dass das
tier zusammen todeszeitpunkt etwa zwei
monate alt war schon früher gab es immer
mal wieder spektakuläre funde aus dieser
region beispielsweise die überreste
eines höhlenlöwen mammuts und
wollnashörner die große hoffnung vieler
forschungsteams solche ausgestorbenen
spezies wieder aufleben zu lassen genau
das haben wir es wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler aus russland und
südkorea auf den plan
sie haben verkündet das fohlen schon
bald klonen zu können in der zeitung
sieht sein wollen
in der zeitung sie beginnt ein sagt
einer der beteiligten
stammzellenforscher rosig waren wir
werden versuchen aus entnommenen
gewebeproben kulturen anzulegen sollte
und dass bei diesem uralten pferd
gelingen könnten unsere methoden auch
auf andere projekte angewendet werden
konkret plant das team ein modernes
fährt als ersatzmutter für die geklonten
eck wo es ines embryonen einzusetzen
voraussetzung dafür wäre lediglich eine
einzige
rekonstruierte zelle des konservierten
polens so die forscher und forscherinnen
doch genau da dürfen nicht gerade
einfach im gegenteil bisher sei es noch
nie gelungen eine zelle mit solch einem
uralten erbgut zu gewinnen doch wann und
seinen kollegen und kolleginnen sind
optimistisch und bezeichnen ihren ganzen
plan als machbar
das hätten experimente mit eingefrorenen
ausziehen gezeigt konkret setzen sie auf
gut erhalten das muskelgewebe um noch
intakte zellen aufzuspüren doch wie
realistisch sind diese pläne wirklich
interessanter da ganze sache ist die
vorgeschichte von wo sobald er betreibt
eine art cologne fabrik in der jeden tag
etwa 500 neue tiere produziert werden
hier geht es um verstorbene haustiere
meist und mit ihrer dna schafft bank
lohne mit denen er dann wiederum die
trauernden besitzer glücklich macht und
das ziemlich erfolgreich konkret
funktioniert das mit hilfe des
somatischen zellkern transfers ein
verfahren bei dem die hautzellen des
tieres genutzt werden das geklont werden
soll hier wird dann der kern entfernt
und in eine eizelle ohne eigenen
zellkern eingesetzt die hundebesitzer
kostet das einige tausend us-dollar hat
sein wohl größter clou gelangen waren
2005 als es ihm gelang snooki zyklon
snoopy steht für seo national university
papi und meint einen afghanischen wind
und seine erbinformation der ohren
seines vaters endung knapp 1100 embryos
wurden in die gebärmutter von 123
hündinnen eingesetzt und es gab
tatsächlich zu drei schwangerschaften
snoopy ist der einzig überlebende ein
wirklicher erfolg der 2006 von dem
amerikanischen national human genome
research institute als solcher bestätigt
wurde
der weltweit erste geklonte hund wann
galt seitdem als pionier der
stammzellenforschung doch dann ging es
mit ihm bergab bis 2005 war er professor
an der universität in tirol bis dann
herauskam dass er riesige datenmengen
gefälscht hatte mittlerweile steht sein
name für einen der größten forschung
skandale dieser zeit konkret ging es um
ein experiment aus
2004 hatte man behauptet erstmals
stammzellen linien aus einem geklonten
menschlichen embryo entwickelt haben
nach einigen angaben habe er diese dann
auf einzelne patienten zugeschnitten
später kam allerdings heraus dass er
einen seiner mitarbeiterinnen benutzt
hatte das hatte die wahl 2005 selbst
zugegeben ein jahr später kam dann eine
untersuchung heraus die seine gesamte
stammzellforschung für gefälscht
erklärte
nichtsdestotrotz wangs plan bezüglich
des fohlens aus dem sibirischen
permafrost ist klar und er ist
tatsächlich nicht der einzige der dieses
ziel nämlich ausgestorbene tierarten
wieder zum leben zu erwecken verfolgt ja
wir haben hier darüber bei pixum hier
schon mal berichtet es geht um mammuts
mars wandert tauben und den magen brüter
frosch alle längst ausgestorben
dennoch besteht die hoffnung dass sie
demnächst vielleicht wieder auf der erde
leben könnten das ist der plan der so
genannten die extinction bewegungen das
sind diejenigen leute die sich um die
wiederbelebung ausgestorbener tierarten
kümmern wie beispielsweise auch der
genetiker george church von der
renommierten harvard university in
boston er will ein embryo entwickeln das
halb elefant und halt wollhaarmammut ist
und dass in naher zukunft das hat der
anfang letzten jahres auf einer
wichtigen wissenschaftskonferenz in
boston verkündet auch andere
forschungsteams weltweit arbeiten schon
jagt seit jahrzehnten daran längst
ausgestorbene tiere von den toten zu
erwecken vor rund 14 jahren hat die
zellkerne aus dem letzten exemplar der
ausgestorbenen pyrenäen steinberg
entnommen und diese in ziegen eingesetzt
und das ganze war wirklich
vielversprechend im sommer 2003 kam ein
steinberg klein zur welt das allerdings
nach wenigen minuten er steht die ganze
idee die heutzutage noch wie science
fiction klingt ruft natürlich auch
kritiker auf den plan sie werfen den
beteiligten forschungsteams vor sich wie
gott auf zu spielen doch ist es auf der
anderen seite nicht eine art korrektur
werden wir menschen ausgestorbene tiere
zurück bringen deren ausrottung wir
selbst zu verantworten haben andere
kritiker sprechen von frankenstein
methoden und wieder andere fordern das
investierte geld besser zu nutzen um
noch lebende arten zu schützen ja wenn
euch das video gefallen hat dann
abonniert doch klicks um natürlich nicht
die
vergessen oder werden sogar mitglied mit
einem kleinen beitrag tut ihr gutes wir
schalten damit nämlich immer mehr
werbung vor den videos ab und ihr
bekommt ein paar spannende extras
einfach hier unter dem video
draufklicken oder auf den link in der
video beschreibung und hier geht es
weiter mit dass mamut wiederbeleben
doktor frankenstein wird realität dafür
also hier klicken und über whatsapp
bekommt er die video links übrigens vor
allen anderen vor mir dafür hier klicken
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran